la transformation numérique pour les tpe
pme artisans consiste à s'approprier les
bénéfices que vont pouvoir tirer ces
professionnels des différents outils
numériques qui correspondent à leur
métier pour le commerçant ça va être de
pouvoir faire de la vente en ligne pour
des clients qui sont peut-être pas
proximité de chez eux de façon à pouvoir
élargir son sa clientèle un des
meilleurs moyens pour faire sa
transition numérique et de regarder ce
que font ses confrères et le deuxième
c'est de se documenter et de suivre
éventuellement soit des tutoriels soit
des formations en ligne
[Musique]
les artisans qui ne s'approprie pas le
numérique aujourd'hui risque de se faire
hubert ise parce qu'ils vont le faire
donc ça peut être une question de survie
et les outils numériques qui permettent
de faciliter le collaboratif sont plus
en plus important les réseaux sociaux y
contribuer notamment et ça beaucoup
d'entreprises aujourd'hui n'ont pas
conscience de l'importance que ça peut
avoir en france le coût de la compétence
informatique et de 8500 euros par an par
salarié
ce chiffre a tout simplement été obtenue
en regardant en étudiant quel était le
temps perdu par les salariés dans les
entreprises à faire un montage quand ils
ne connaissaient pas bien l'outil
informatique qui leur permettait de bien
faire cette tâche ou de la faire
rapidement